cpj
is effective to go someplace and talk to
the prime minister
or the president or the justice minister
and say you need to let these people
free
you put them in jail because you want to
shut them up
you can't shut us up breaking news
you're going to be
seeing some video here that we have just
coming tens of thousands of protesters
are calling for government reform
it's a growing crackdown in europe in
italy one of the deadliest
days yet they are already at 100 icu
capacity
protesters have taken to the streets
around the world to protest against
racism and discrimination
as police crack down on the protests
journalists have also found themselves
being targeted local
as well as foreign journalists have
often been in the thick of
it we've seen journalists being arrested
with tear gas
[Music]
in recent weeks being a journalist does
not make you immune to being
harassed by police abuses against the
media are getting worse
over the last week they've arrested
dozens of journalists
the costs of being a journalist add up
when you're in countries that don't
respect press freedom and that's exactly
where cpj steps in
freedom of the press is the foundation
of
every single right you have we are not
ending this fight then in the face of
danger
journalists continue to place their
lives on the line to bring the unheard
stories from the darkest parts of the
world
you could not have been more
professional you were doing your job
by the book i know they've been through
a lot and they are very strong
tough fierce journalists i can hear gwen
right now
saying to each one of us keep your head
down
keep working now is not the time to grow
weary
welcome thank you for joining us for the
2020 international press freedom awards
presented by the committee to protect
journalists the powerful video that we
just saw
is the reason we're here whether
covering the pandemic
or protests journalists everywhere are
under attack
the very truth they seek to bring us is
under attack
and shortly we're going to meet some of
the brave reporters that we just saw and
learn how we can support a free press
and to guide us there it's my pleasure
to introduce committee to protect
journalists board member
and anchor of the nbc nightly news and
dateline nbc
lester holt
hi everyone i'm lester holt every year
the committee to protect journalists on
whose board i am proud to serve honors
courageous journalists from around the
world at this event
for nearly 40 years the committee to
protect journalists
has stood shoulder to shoulder with
reporters around the globe
who brave violence and intimidation just
for bringing us the news
and i doubt that the committee has ever
been more needed than right now
what a time we're living through rarely
in our lifetimes has the need for
accurate and timely information been
greater
we are awash with misinformation and
lies
the pandemic has emboldened autocrats
everywhere to crack down on descent
and civil liberties in democratic
countries
leaders have undermined their own
institutions and health experts
in their attempt to downplay the crisis
independent journalism
is a bulwark against this erosion of
freedom and slide into confusion
journalists around the globe have taken
up the challenge to keep
citizens informed sometimes
the price of their own freedom such
sacrifice
is a common theme at these cpj awards
this year is no exception tonight we
will hear from an
international community of journalists
news reporters
familiar faces and surprising guests
who have all gathered to honor the work
of four journalists
from russia nigeria iran and bangladesh
who have paid a heavy price for their
quest
after the truth i am honored to be here
and welcome you to join us in this fight
for press freedom
[Music]
hi i'm patrick gaspard president of the
open society foundations
i am honored to be the chair of this
year's international press freedom
awards
for three decades these awards have
focused attention
on the struggles of independent
reporters and editors
around the world they recognize courage
and professionalism
in the face of cruel oppression they
also give encouragement
to those journalists in jail or in exile
for their work
the covert 19 pandemic has shown us all
what a world without accurate
information can look like
so many people have suffered so many
people have died
in part because those in power
manipulated or bungled
the flow of information we need skeptics
and people who ask tough questions to
hold our leaders to account
that means we need journalists and
journalists
need protection i am supporting the
committee to protect journalists
join me
hello from london now u.s sanctions have
crippled iran's access to medical
supplies but still the country has been
scrambling
to cover up the extent and impact of
covet 19
on the country at one point it even
suspended the printing and distribution
of all newspapers despite intimidation
and the ever-present threat of ending up
in tehran's notorious evie in prison
independent journalists have persisted
in bringing us the truth
one such is our next honoree a dogged
investigative reporter
who is just this year been sentenced to
nearly five years in prison
he is mohammed
[Music]
these are scarce pictures from protests
in iran
the iranian government has shut down
nearly all internet access in the
country
there are pockets of access that have
let people show what's happening on the
ground but they're rare
making it very hard to figure out what
exactly is going on there with the
protest
situation of press freedom in iran
there is no press freedom
everything is state-run whoever is not
happy with what you report as a
journalist their first
measure is to silence you you
always have to watch your back always
have to watch your communications
muhammad was arrested in the middle of
nationwide
street protests
this tweet is one of the reasons he was
arrested
he was detained for over a month
all of it he was in solitary confinement
helping these journalists like muhammad
has become
personal for me i am an iranian
journalist
i was detained for over two and a half
months
in solitary confinement
it's like being alive put force
into a grave
me and my colleagues at the committee to
protect journalists
got involved with muhammad's case
we immediately put statements out
and launching a social media campaign
on his behalf
on august 25th muhammad received his
final sentence
[Music]
the only reason he got such a heavy
sentence is because of his
effort to tell the truth
it's because of these journalists on the
ground that we sometimes hear oh there
was a flood
there's a war there's a pandemic we know
that there are forces in the system who
do not
want the truth to be shared
with the outside world he's being
punished
only for being a very truthful
journalist
[Music]
the four journalists whose stories we're
hearing give us a glimpse into the
battle for press freedom
in honoring their struggle and their
sacrifice we send a signal of hope and
solidarity to the thousands of other
journalists
who endure attacks the loss of
livelihood
the loss of liberty and sometimes even
the loss of life that comes with being
an independent voice
in so much of the world their reporting
has brought
light into these dark times tyrants love
the dark
it cloaks their misdeeds and their lies
by supporting cpj you are also helping
journalists
everywhere bring us the light of truth
[Music]
congratulations to all of the honorees
as usual at this event it's an amazing
and courageous group of women and men
for more than 30 years
knight foundation has supported the
committee to protect journalists
because press freedom is the lifeblood
of citizen engagement in any republic
around the world
there simply isn't a more effective
organization
supporting the free press especially in
the crisis
we're proud of our significant
investment in cpj
including our most recent grant four
million dollars
for their headquarters and endowment i'm
here to ask you for your support
every dollar you give as part of this
event will be matched
dollar for dollar by night foundation
so if you give fifty dollars it'll be a
hundred if you give a thousand dollars
it'll be two thousand dollars
give any amount but please get
if you're moved by the courage and
tenacity of the honorees
give if you believe in informed
communities and accountable government
you should give
knight foundation will double your gift
and we're delighted to do so
thank you
[Music]
independent journalism in nigeria today
owes a
debt of gratitude to our next awardee
who began fighting for a free press back
in the 1990s
his tempo magazine angered that
country's military dictatorship
so much that it issued a shoot on site
order against him
after he was forced into hiding to
escape arrest in 1995.
he survived the dictator fell
since then he has continued that fight
for press freedom
all the while working as a prolific
journalist and founder of news sites
it is my great pleasure to introduce the
man
sometimes known as the godfather of
online journalism
in nigeria dabo olurunyomi
we have political institutions
that do not believe in the idea of press
freedom
freedom of the press is purely
theoretical in nigeria a journalist
is a moving target journalists in
nigeria work under
very difficult conditions for societies
like us
the press is the only hope for the
possibility
of an opposition
1996 they put us on charges of treason
my colleague said listen you you
really have to leave the country at this
time
cpj and the amnesty international
collaborated and got me
out of nigeria it's not part of the plan
but it's like today you have to move
that's how a 13 years exile
began
my years of exile was working to free
many of my colleagues were in jail
providing media support for the kinds of
work that they do
so i said okay let's try to do something
we'll publish
online and that's how premium council is
founded
not just for democracy but for press
freedom especially
in nigeria the advent of premium times
changed online journalism in this
country
we are the only nigerian newspaper
invited to be part of the panama papers
2017 we had written
a story about the head of the nigerian
army
i was arrested alongside the colonial me
when i did a report
which the chief of army staff at the
time did not find so comfortable
the committee to protect journalists
quickly
he jumped in in fact it was one of the
biggest case of advocacy
i've ever seen my life
ordinarily i know we'll probably have
rocks in jail
but i mean they were forced to release
us
you know the very next day
you can't stop media from doing its work
at what is clearly established in
section 22 in a young constitution
to hold people in power accountable at
all times that's what the law says
my own relationship with the community
protector is a very long one
just hearing that people are making
calls i'm
putting pressure for your release that
keeps you going
once hope is that we'll be able to
design new ways to fund
accountability journalism in the country
this is this central challenge for press
freedom i think
in nigeria
[Music]
our world is changing faster than ever
every morning
we wake up to news of protests natural
disasters
police brutality fake news a global
pandemic
the world ending to navigate this world
we
need information and we depend on a free
press
to bring it to us we need to know the
truth
because truth means freedom freedom from
censorship
freedom from tyranny freedom from
oppression from corrupt governments
freedom from misinformation
from the abuse of power from lies but
this freedom can only happen
in a world when freedom of speech and a
free press
is protected for me a free press
guarantees the freedom to make jokes
to have an opinion speak truth to power
seek the truth
protest to write a story to make art to
criticize and contextualize the facts
to speak out fight back and stand up
stand up
stand up stand up for what is right join
us and donate to the committee to
protect journalists
let's all fight for a free press
[Music]
russia knows how to silence critics
political opponents often keel over from
poison
independent journalists are often
stifled through intimidation
harassment short of detention or
physical attack does not make for
screaming international headlines
and for that reason is probably even
more effective
the court system is a favorite tool of
the kremlin for oppression
prosecution after bogus prosecution can
crush the life out of a reporter
here is one journalist who refuses to
let that happen
slotlana prachaplavia
is a journalist who works for radio free
europe radio liberty
and she also worked for a liberal radio
station
echo of moscow she got in trouble
for the comments she made in the
broadcast on a terrorist attack
so
uh in russia you don't have to be a
well-known outspoken journalist or
critic
of president putin himself to be
prosecuted
for your opinion we immediately jumped
on the case we
spoke to svetlana we issued an alert
and the russian journalistic community
demonstrated solidarity
in defending svetlana over a dozen
protesters many of them journalists
were detained by the police in moscow on
friday
foreign
[Music]
the court did find her guilty
of justifying terrorism but
fortunately she wasn't sentenced to
a jail term she ended up with a huge
fine
and she is still under the travel ban
svetlana's case was a case where
freedom of expression and press freedom
was put on trial
if we at the committee to protect
journalists
don't help those journalists don't speak
out
in defense of them who else is going to
do it
[Music]
my name is kathleen carroll advocate for
press freedom
and board chair of the committee to
protect journalists
today you don't need to be a
professional journalist to report the
news
today 280 characters
can carry a message that will be heard
around the world
a video taken by your cell phone can
bear witness to actions
that might otherwise be erased the
internet can be a platform for people to
speak
loudly even when governments try to
silence them
but today those very tools have ushered
in
a new era of propaganda it is more
difficult than ever to decipher what is
real
and what is not join me in defending our
access to facts
join me in celebrating brave and
accurate reporting
because press freedom is not just about
protecting journalists
it's about your right to share your
story and engage the world
press freedom is your freedom
[Music]
we all know that at its heart journalism
is about storytelling
and our next award winner is a master of
the craft in words
and even more so in pictures for more
than three decades his photographs of
his native bangladesh have provided
powerful
insights into the social and political
upheaval in his country
his brave reporting led to his detention
two years ago
freed on bail after four months a legal
case against him remains open
but no government has been able to shut
down one of bangladesh's great
photojournalists
shahidullah
[Music]
we live in a very visual world
we are constantly immersed in images
we told how to think by other people who
use images to direct our minds
for a photojournalist our need is to
tell the story
our need is to ensure the message goes
out
we have to be at the forefront and
therefore we are perceived as the
biggest threat
joining us now via skype from dhaka is
a photographer and social activist i
think the government has miscalculated
it certainly felt that fear was enough
repression would have been enough
but you cannot tame an entire nation in
this manner
i've just given this interview to al
jazeera i was uploading my pictures
and the doorbell rang
has been arrested charged with spreading
false information about recent student
protests
on august 5th 2018 i got messages from
my sources in bangladesh saying that
shahido has been detained
the moment the committee to protect
journalists heard
we knew we had to get to work right away
we helped his family organize a protest
outside of the un general assembly to
put pressure on the bangladeshi
government
there was a massive coalition in
bangladesh as well that was coordinating
information i don't know that the
government
really knew the amount of backlash they
would face
it was immediate
i was tortured i went to jail and there
were times when i thought i might not
live
i was finally released on the 20th of
november
around 107 days after i was picked up
[Music]
it's not an individual effort it's a
community effort
we are dependent on journalists standing
up in solidarity
others who are willing to fight this
fight along with us
because there's power in numbers
it was very very important that
spotlight was not a spotlight just in me
but a spotlight on bangladesh spotlight
and repression
and i felt then as i do now that if we
can continue
that resistance and if that support
continues
we have a chance of writing a wrong
[Music]
the journalists we have just met
svetlana depo
muhammad and shaido are exceptional and
unfortunately their stories
are typical of the hundreds of
journalists that cpj
supports each year cpj's dedicated staff
report on attacks on the press
and mount campaigns and advocacy in
defense of the press
this all under the leadership of our
next speaker
the executive director of cpj joel simon
[Music]
smartphones have made it possible for
people around the world
to document what they see and to say
what they think
we are all journalists if you will we
all have the same rights
whether guaranteed in the first
amendment or an international law
but we still need the professionals who
go out every day
and take the risks ask the hard
questions
gather the facts we want to be informed
we want to be connected we want to be
heard
but there are risks for those who
challenge power and who dare to tell the
truth
we at the committee to protect
journalists are proud to stand up
and defend the rights of the journalists
who keep us informed
we're active in every place journalists
are under threat
it takes money to run that kind of
global operation
that's why i want to take a moment to
say thank you
thank you to everyone who gave because
they were inspired
by our honorees thank you to those who
support cpj
year after year thank you to the
foundations and philanthropies
whose grants underwrite our work thank
you
to everyone who cares about press
freedom who values and supports the work
of journalists
and who speaks out when press freedom is
under threat thank you and thank you to
meryl streep who will now introduce the
gwen ifill press freedom award winner
i'm all clooney
[Music]
the late gwen ifill a beloved reporter
who anchored the pbs evening news once
said
we cannot expect the world to get better
by itself
we have to create something we can leave
the next generation
gwen died four years ago and through her
defense of press freedom she has left us
a legacy which we can
carry forward gwen was a supporter and
long-time board member of the committee
to protect journalists which has named
an award
in her honor the gwen ifill award is
given
every year for extraordinary and
sustained achievement
in the cause of press freedom this
evening's award
is presented to a woman who exemplifies
the tireless struggle for press freedom
and
justice and she's not only something
every journalist needs which is a great
lawyer
but she's also a defender of the
international laws
that make free expression possible
tonight we honor her work to ensure that
governments and
tyrants are made accountable for their
unprecedented attacks
on press freedom it's my great honor to
announce
amal clooney as the 2020 recipient
of the gwen ifill award
amal brings her skill as an advocate and
her expertise in international human
rights law
to help free journalists who are
unjustly imprisoned
and to protect those who face such
imprisonment
we're facing a free speech crisis in the
world today and it's extremely
concerning
record numbers of journalists are being
abused across the world
through vilification threats
surveillance imprisonment
even murder she has defended journalists
around the world and helped win their
freedom
among them muhammad fami an al jazeera
journalist
investigative reporter khadijah
ismailova
jailed in azerbaijan and in myanmar
reuters journalists
amal has represented clients before
courts such as the international
criminal court
and the european court of human rights
her organization the clooney foundation
for justice
monitors press freedom violations and
provides
free legal representation for those in
greatest need
it is time to make justice your priority
so that history can record what happened
so that we can stop it from happening
[Music]
again
i am so honored to be able to
to call the winner of the 2020 gwen
ifill press freedom award
not only a dear friend but somebody who
has
enabled us here in rappler in the
philippines to actually do our work
and someone who i hope will continue
doing that work so that we stay out of
jail
um we are halfway around the world from
each other but
please join us in this conversation with
amal clooney
amal it is so good to see you hello
maria it's so good to see you as well
i wish we could be in the same room but
this will have to do for now
thank you cpj for giving me the chance
to ask her
questions instead of her grilling me to
prepare for this i looked at
everything you did in your life and you
know very very impressive oxford
university
nyu law a professor at columbia law
school
uh but the crucial question why do you
do
what you do i think one of the reasons i
do it
is because i know how lucky i am
i you know i was born in lebanon
at a time when that country was going
through a civil war and
i was lucky enough my family was able to
leave the country and we
moved to the uk as refugees and from
there
anything was possible but i think
another part of it though
is frankly um anger
i think anger drives a lot of what i do
because
um when i read about what's happening in
many places in the world
i just feel a sense of outrage that
those in power are abusing their power
today in 2020
i see in far too many places the those
who are
committing human rights abuses are free
and those who are reporting on them
are imprisoned and i will continue to
focus on trying to tackle
both problems um you know
and i thank you for being so determined
to continue the work that
you do oh no i mean thank you for that
and it and we are so much better because
you do what you do right but
when you're facing such seemingly
hopeless cases
where this amal where does hope come
from for you
well i i don't know i mean i would ask
you the same question
it never occurs to me to do otherwise
um i suppose it's more um
it's that that's the default and i think
actually the worse the situation gets
you know you ask me why
the focus on journalists i didn't start
my career
thinking i'm going to focus on cases
involving journalists i
decided to focus my career on cases
involving human rights and you can't
defend human rights if journalists can't
do their work you can't defend democracy
if you don't have
a thriving and independent media but the
more i see
autocratic regimes becoming determined
to silence those who disagree with them
to silence those who expose the truth or
corruption or things that embarrass them
the more determined we have to be you
know they're becoming more creative in
their
methods um and so we need to become um
more savvy in our response and so i
think journalists have a part to play
lawyers have a part to play senators
have a part to play
my name means hope so i'm i'm destined
to be an optimist
so amal tonight you are getting the
committee to protect journalists their
gwen eiffel press freedom award
what does this mean to you well i feel
so honored um to get this award the
committee to protect journalists does
incredible work
i couldn't do my work without them i
rely on their data i you know i i
brainstorm with them and they are
um really professional and really
devoted and so
you know i think we both feel very
strongly that uh
journalism is the lifeblood of democracy
and that this is
you know something we have to continue
to fight for uh i know how powerful
a defender you are and we and rapper are
just so lucky to have you
on our side your taking my case helps
give me the courage to
do what we're doing to continue standing
up to power because i know that
you know god forbid if something happens
and i tell you this all the time
i know you're there what kind of
pressure does that put on you
well i i do feel pressure um when i work
on cases like yours
um and i you know to some degree your
case does keep me up at night
and and so it should because you might
be the one in the dock but it's actually
democracy that's on trial if if
you can be taken away in handcuffed and
silenced then
every other journalist in the country
knows what they need to do to stay safe
it's not a fair contest you know you
have the truth on your side
but um your foe is
the most powerful person in the country
and
the you know the other side of this case
is the government that controls the
police and controls the army and
controls the prosecutors and potentially
controls the courts so
i think we are asking a lot of
journalists
um you know i think you're incredibly
courageous but you shouldn't
need to be this courageous it's too much
to ask it's too much pressure on people
like you and i think that's why the
system has to change most people may not
realize your mom
was uh is a journalist right uh
how has this affected you what has she
done how has her work affected you
well i mean i definitely um watched her
admiringly
uh you know she was a journalist
initially in lebanon and then
um a foreign correspondent based in the
uk but i grew up sort of watching her
rushing to finish her her columns um
and it you know it's it's it's in the
family my husband's father is also a
veteran
journalist and it's definitely something
close to both of our hearts
um it's it's in our families and and it
means that it's
uh it's difficult to get a word in
edgeways at our family dinner tables
thank you thank you amal hope
and you know really a fuel for courage
for us to keep doing what we do
thank you so much maria thank you and it
was a pleasure
thank you for joining us in honoring
these courageous journalists across the
globe
please continue to support the committee
to protect journalists and rally for our
collective fight
for press freedom to end the night
please enjoy a final musical performance
take care everyone and good night
hi my name is lee ronaldo this song is
called thrown over the wall
the lyrics were co-written with author
jonathan lethem
based on words ripped directly from the
headlines let's remember that there are
journalists like tonight's honorees who
are willing to risk their lives
or go to jail to bring us the news this
song is for them
we use the sea to hide our
submarines
disguise our faces with names
we use the night to conceal our dreams
and clouds to hide our aeroplanes
we smuggle facts inside a magazine
[Music]
interpret sadness as shame
you swung hide a hammer to teach them
to believe
bury the lead behind the frame
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Music]
[Music]
thrown over the wall again
[Music]
we use the sea to hide our
submarines
disguise our faces with names
we use the night to conceal our dreams
[Music]
and clouds to hide our aeroplanes
[Music]
and call an eclipse
[Music]
the child to unholster the guns
[Music]
[Music]
again
again
[Music]